So how would you use formal logic to
develop an agent that can solve Raven's
progressive matrices?
As with production systems, we can kind
of face this at two different levels.
One, you could use formal logic to
represent the overall algorithm
the agent uses to solve any new problem.
Or secondly, the agent could use formal
logic to develop its understanding of
a new problem that just came in.
It could then use those formal rules to
develop the transformations that occur
within the problem and transfer those
transformations into the new answer.
Alternatively, you could also use formal
logic to allow your agent to prove why
it's answer to a particular
problem is correct.
Then if the answer is
actually incorrect,
the agent may have the information
necessary to go back and
repair it's reasoning and
do better next time.